well right now president biden is  walking back a veto threat which threw  the bipartisan infrastructure bill into  danger of actually not passing the  president threatened a veto  unless the senate also passed his  americans family's plan  now that plan would fund what he calls  human infrastructure  child care free community college and  green energy  the president reversed his comments over  the weekend  we were assured that the two would not  be linked  yes the human infrastructure if you will  as they call it  would be pursued but the two would not  be linked republicans think  that portion is bad for our country if  the senate is going to move forward with  a bipartisan infrastructure bill  we must also move forward on a budget  resolution  as well and democratic leaders adding  they want to vote on  both of these bills next month